you kind of look exactly like Christian
Bale in the new Moses movie Oh your
facial hair is exactly like him your
hairstyle is similar isn't this hair
longer usually nope it's a weirdest
thing about that movie hey guys I'm Ryan
right I'm Dan Severn and tonight we're
gonna check out the trailer
this one is Hercules the videogame uh
well I'm assuming that this is uh for
the Dwayne Johnson join jocks and so I
mean if it is based off the movie we all
know how movie video games go and vice
versa yeah there's some of the best
games ever
I played Terminator 2 on Super Nintendo
I can never get past the first level and
if I was fortunate enough to get past it
I died immediately on the second level
where you're riding a motorcycle with
snap so if you crash into one thing you
die oh wait what am I talking about the
Hercules PlayStation game for the Disney
movie that was it awesome so let's do it
there's hope after all there's hope
maybe it maybe it's a Hercules thing
yeah yeah
I need sleep Oh is this for iPhone no
this looks like a mobile
download on the app store
alright alright I'm watching that I'm
like that one doesn't look next-gen to
what no yeah that uh that's mobile might
be a fun mobile game if that's a big
maybe it's here's the thing is that just
looking at it right now I think they're
really trying to capture what Infinity
Blade has done on the iPhone don't know
if you've played it now I haven't
actually played it but I know it it is a
really good really good you split that
game was awesome and it had like pretty
freaking awesome plot line that looks
like I'm on the bus yeah it doesn't look
too anything too special actually I
don't even know which one was Hercules
yeah yeah it's maybe I make it from
behind we were Hercules but I don't know
[ __ ] better be free oh yeah that's the
most important fact that should be free
and if there's any in-game buys forget
it I'm not doing it I mean that no
sister if it's free I'll do it ya know I
might no I'll just take up space on my
phone yeah that's true well guys thank
you for recommending a 30 second trailer
okay if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects here
and dan has a gaming channel that cyber
channel you can subscribe to it right
here I'm gonna do some shoutouts weirder
shoutouts Allen Orianna can i get a
shout out well Oriana yes you can
I would assume you're a girl if I just
heard your last thing why is that the
last name yeah Oriana doesn't sound like
a female Spanish name to you when I say
Seibert what gender you think of well I
didn't realize your name was like
spelled like Siberia for real yeah well
I got I mean I got my YouTube one that's
cyb ERT yeah but I guess there's no
secret it's Seib ERT okay yeah so it's a
shaman that's cool play on words that he
did there Alan you are a special young
man I'm assuming you're young based off
your thumbnail even though you're not
into them
it just looks like what a little kid
would do so I can't is it Mario it is
Mario we like your taste in games we
like your taste in games and soon enough
when you're older you'll like your taste
in [ __ ] Marcus green I could have sworn
I give you a shout out and you see you
watch all my videos all of them yeah he
says he watches every single one of them
he says he's doesn't god I'm one but I'm
like whatever whatever I could be wrong
I tend to be actually so Marcus green
I'm finally giving you a shadow you send
our videos make your day
well how much time are you spending on
this channel are you doing anything
productive lately because don't get me
wrong I feel like the view is a lot you
should keep camping you should keep
doing it but maybe you should add
something else here but on top of that
we want a five page thesis on every
reaction - that would be cool that's due
tomorrow that will be cool no I'm
kidding I don't care what you do with
your life just [ __ ] keep watching our
videos that's awesome star bits master
can I get a shoutout sorry if I'm being
annoying you're not being annoying star
bits master no no no this would be
here's a hi package yeah that's annoying
that would have been real star bits
master you are not a star bit you are
star full and don't you forget that
because you were the master of the stars
oh my god I'm talking to God right now
are you God
I always thought God was some distant
beans but what if God was one of us a
youtuber like one of us trying to find
his few count brother